[Musica]
c'è una domanda ricorrente che
probabilmente riguarda anche alcuni di
voi è una domanda che ci facciamo in
particolare se abbiamo figli fratelli e
sorelle se siamo particolarmente in
contatto con la nuova generazione
È una domanda che non solo ci preoccupa
Ma è una domanda a cui oggi non abbiamo
una risposta e la domanda è
siamo dipendenti dai nuovi media dei
social media delle tecnologie da chat
GPT dall'intelligenza artificiale tutto
quello che arriverà
ora facciamo un test Quanti di voi
pensano che ci sia un problema con un
uso eccessivo delle tecnologie non per
forza per voi ma anche per la nuova
generazione o per qualcuno magari che
conoscete chi lo pensi alzi la mano
Ok i dati ci dicono esattamente questo
cioè ci dicono che esattamente c'è un
problema riguardante un uso smodato
delle tecnologie e che pensiamo che
questo digitale a volte sia un po' come
un qualcosa che effettivamente ci fa
star bene C'è utile ma non sempre
riusciamo a regolarci se ve lo dovessi
descrivere vi parlerei di una frase di
un docufilm che forse avete visto si
chiama The Social dilemma e dice ci sono
solo due Industrie che chiamano gli
utenti users l'industria delle
tecnologie e l'industria delle droghe
legali
ora Io oggi sono qui a dirvi che stiamo
vedendo il problema dalla parte
sbagliata dobbiamo girare il quadro
cambiare la prospettiva perché non è il
digitale ad essere il problema
e ve lo dico perché per me è un problema
che mi è stato particolarmente a cuore
ho lavorato per cinque anni fino a pochi
mesi fa in meta L'azienda che fa
Facebook Instagram WhatsApp con le app
che usiamo tutti e Effettivamente da
dipendente ho avuto la possibilità al
privilegio di poter vedere delle grandi
innovazioni all'interno dell'azienda da
dietro le quinte al racconto del
metaverso l'evoluzione dei sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale
Io sono un amante della tecnologia un
amante del digitale vero entusiasta però
se facevo due passetti indietro e
guardavo il quadro un po' più ampio mi
sembrava di aver davanti una calamita
Avete presente una calamita da un polo
le tecnologie dall'altra parte le
persone che pian piano si avvicinavano
pensate che Instagram Ovviamente nel
2011 riguardava solo gli instagrammer
quelli che fanno foto post eccetera oggi
ci sono tutti Inclusi i governi politici
istituzioni e sanità eccetera eccetera
era una forza di attrazione
quello che ho capito è che se volevo
comprendere meglio questa forza di
attrazione che da una parte mi
entusiasmava dall'altra un po' mi
preoccupava non potevo studiare solo il
digitale l'industria in cui lavoravo ma
dovevo guardare l'altra parte la
rivoluzione mentale che c'è nei nostri
cervelli e che stiamo ovviamente Vivendo
e quindi ho detto studio mi sono
iscritto un master in cui c'entravo
pochissimo dipendenze da nuovi media in
età adolescenziale tenuto da una scuola
di psicoterapia
psicoterapia il Minotauro in
collaborazione con l'ospedale Gemelli di
Roma pensate il primo ospedale ad avere
un reparto di dipendenze da internet per
gli adolescenti all'interno del reparto
di psichiatria
ora queste due esperienze insieme mi
hanno fatto arrivare alla conclusione
che oggi vi ho anticipato Cioè che il
problema non è il digitale il digitale è
lo specchio che riflette un'immagine ed
è di quelle immagine che ci dovremo
preoccupare Però per arrivare a questa
conclusione facciamo un passo indietro
Partiamo dalla rivoluzione tecnologica
Ok inizia Con l'avvento del web dura
fino a oggi ci siamo dentro ci siamo
dentro tutti
e ovviamente è una rivoluzione che ha un
grande impatto se ve la dovessi
descrivere Se dovessi parlarne in un
libro di storia Parlerai di due
caratteristiche che l'hanno
effettivamente identificata La prima è
lo stravolgimento del ruolo dell'utente
tutti noi siamo Cambiati da spettatore a
direttore di rete e media volenti o
nolenti siamo tutti direttore di rete
Perché i contenuti quando Apri Instagram
tiktok Facebook te li scegli e media
perché potenzialmente ognuno di noi può
raggiungere un audience grandissima
la seconda caratteristica
riguarda Ovviamente come questo è stato
fatto e questo è stato fatto dando tre
cose ognuno Il primo è accesso ai
contenuti Il secondo è relazione con gli
altri e il terzo è risposte
personalizzate in questo aggettivo
personalizzate c'è la plasticità delle
piattaforme una delle cose che mi
affascinava di più il fatto che Le
piattaforme danno risposte
personalizzate Quindi se qui abbiamo già
cose impossibili due di voi che seguono
gli stessi utenti su Tik Tok comunque
verrete cose diverse perché ovviamente
Le piattaforme raccolgono i dati questi
dati sono elaborati dall'intelligenza
artificiale vi vengono date risposte
personalizzate
e ovviamente quindi questo cambia
totalmente le cose perché ovviamente
abbiamo una rivoluzione del potere da
poche persone i proprietari di media a
tante potenzialmente tutti e uno
stravolgimento ovviamente il ruolo
dell'utente ora se questo discorso
risulta un po' complesso facciamo un
viaggio Disegniamo delle vette in cima
alle vette ci mettiamo le motivazioni
che ci portano a usare Le piattaforme
ognuna ne avrà una diversa ad esempio
sono in metropolitana a Milano voglio
intrattenermi perché mi sto annoiando
Voglio vendere più prodotti sul mio
eshop voglio imparare a suonare la
chitarra a queste motivazioni se ne
aggiungono di nuove
come ad esempio Voglio diventare un
influencer e guadagnare grazie alle mie
passioni voglio ancora lanciare un nuovo
media e raggiungere tutti gli abitanti
del mio comune queste motivazioni non
sono poche sono infinite è una catena
montuosa che oggi non conosciamo tutto
tutta perché ovviamente le tecnologie
non sono ancora arrivate tutte ne stanno
arrivando sempre più e come fanno le
piattaforme a convincerci a salire in
quella vetta attraverso dei sentieri che
sono Le piattaforme quindi per imparare
a suonare la chitarra posso usare
Instagram YouTube GarageBand eccetera
eccetera e i proprietari delle
piattaforme che disegnano i sentieri
dicono rendiamo questi sentieri
incredibili talmente belli talmente
mozzafiato con degli scorci fatti
talmente adatti a te che non vuoi fare
altro e quindi ecco arrivare lo
all'infinito su Tik Tok piuttosto che su
Instagram le risposte immediate tutte
tecnologie che puntano lo stesso
obiettivo quello di ovviamente farci
stare proprio su quella piattaforma ora
se noi vogliamo effettivamente capire
che cosa è successo dobbiamo andare
dall'altra parte della calamita la
rivoluzione mentale
la rivoluzione mentale
fondamentalmente ci racconta diverse
cose perché proprio negli studi
umanistici io ho imparato le cose più
interessanti 1 non esistono dipendenze
Ma esistono nuove normalità o meglio è
difficile dividerle come facciamo a
capire se una persona che sta ora su Tik
Tok ha effettivamente una patologia
oppure magari sta imparando un nuovo
lavoro
il DSM Five il manuale diagnostico che
evidenzia tutte le dipendenze ci dice
che non riusciamo a distinguere tra le
nuove normalità e nuove patologie
Non riusciamo perché ovviamente non c'è
conformità nelle etichette diagnostiche
al master vedevamo dei casi clinici di
dei ragazzi che erano effettivamente
dipendenti da videogames ci passavano
nel deore ma quando poi entravamo a
vedere perché avevano dei disturbi
ovviamente depressivi ai quali
compensavano attraverso l'utilizzo dei
media quindi non è così semplice e
immediato quindi capite che serve
conoscenza e consapevolezza la
conoscenza non è semplice per noi da
avere perché quando siamo arrivati ai
piedi di questa catena montuosa eravamo
effettivamente
ammaliati ammaliati dalla Possibilità di
successo dalla possibilità di arrivare e
quindi Eccoci a fare che cosa ovviamente
a dare Potenza al successo che è
arrivato che in cima Chi ha tanti
follower tanti Like a chi ce l'ha fatta
ma contemporaneamente abbiamo dato alito
all'industria del fake nel 2018
lavoriamo in L'Oreal e a un certo punto
avevamo contratti solo con influencer
che avevano effettivamente profili colmi
di fake ho chiesto fermi tutti andiamo a
rivederli da una settimana all'altra ci
siamo ritrovati a lavorare solo con la
metà dell'influencer della settimana
precedente
Ora ovviamente è un discorso complesso
sicuramente molto lungo ma capita che
c'è bisogno di educazione digitale
educazione digitale che possiamo avere
solo tramite l'informazione
non è facile oggi andare nelle
piattaforme e distinguere concetti di
privacy come una un contenuto isolato
privato e personale da concetti pubblici
E questa differenza non è assolutamente
semplice da identificarsi e quindi
ovviamente servirebbe delle informazioni
perché nelle piattaforme l'informazione
responsabilità dell'educazione è sempre
di qualcun altro dei governi delle tette
delle scuole delle istituzioni non ce la
prendiamo mai noi
perché è ovviamente complicato Io oggi
vi dico che non dobbiamo chiederci se
siamo dipendenti dai social media
dobbiamo chiederci Perché la nostra
società ha dato valore a chi è arrivato
in cima dobbiamo chiederci perché
osagniamo questa tecnologia E questa
modalità senza effettivamente aver fatto
un passo indietro
e dobbiamo chiederci Come facciamo a
raggiungere l'informazione adeguata
perché la rivoluzione tecnologica è
nostra E sono noi possiamo attuarla
grazie
[Applauso]